wind it back dj wind it back now i've
got to come up with a different rhyme
for wood carver
oh i hate myself i'm chris hello i'm a
freestyle rapper
i make up wraps on the spot based on
your suggestions thank you so much for
joining us john
uh what would you like to hear a rap
about um
so ages ago my dad bought a magazine
because he was interested in um
he had a hobby so um we should clarify
for americans that means something you
read made out of paper
over here a magazine is something that
you use to wield the power of ammunition
um i'm i'm assuming that you're talking
more like you know uh
you know print media yeah yeah so it was
from
yeah from a magazine of to do with his
hobby um
so 1980 wood carvers convention
1980s wood carvers convention that is
fantastic
thank you so much for that john uh and
thank you john's dad for inspiring i
love that little celebrate like yes
what a suggestion thank you john ben and
rebecca
i like how really you framed this
so that ben is in front of the lovely
lights and the little pattern and then
rebecca's just off on the side like
and i'm here as well hello everybody so
thank you ben for framing it so
wonderfully
what what would you guys like a rap
about i'm gonna go
for midsummer maypole mid-summer maypole
lovely
and let me just clarify you mean
mid-summer the british festival not the
crazy movie by arie astor which is
really scary
the crazy one oh the crazy one oh cool i
i love that movie
the music is by uh bobby krillich the
hacksand cloak and he's
very talented i i like that a lot thank
you very much ben rebecca are you happy
with that were you consulted
yes i'm happy with it we live in sweden
so oh you're in sweden lovely stuff
we've got shafine hey shafeen and and
who is with you shafin
this is my wife siri hello hey siri
yeah just like you've heard all the
jokes you've heard projects
um amazing i imagine you're an alexa fan
because otherwise every time you say
your wife's name
just devices start pinging off i think
you just set her off actually
[Laughter]
what would you like to hear a wrap about
shafina siri um
[Music]
getting a mcdonald's at 3am after you
leave the club
get in mcdonald's at 3 a.m and thank you
for clarifying after you leave the club
it's it's a different experience no it's
not you know post
gig yeah yeah after leaving the club
what would what's your order when you go
to mac as it through
it's a big mac and then lots of nuggets
as well
how many do you go for uh like 15 20
yeah
oh brilliant stuff lovely we need two
more suggestions
what are they gonna be hey andy we've
got andy and who's with you andy
this is my fiancee yina who got you to
do a wrap for me for my birthday last
year
oh that's so nice did you enjoy it or is
this you coming to complain no actually
it wasn't accurate
hey you can hire me to do personalized
freestyle raps on cameo yeah it's
great um so what would you guys like a
rap about
the magic of the rice cooker the magic
of the rice cooker
brilliant stuff i i'm fully on board
since moving
uh to colorado or we stay with my wife's
family uh
we have two rice cookers which you might
think it's too many rice cookers no
just constant having rice available at
all times of the day is perfect you're
like i'm hungry
rice time amazing thank you very much
guys love it let's get one final
suggestion
um who's it gonna be james is here
james sup james what would you like a
rap about
uh how about an mft version of the
dangle painting
an nft version of a van gogh painting
thank you very much
let's spotlight this beautiful face back
on this is a wrap
made up on the spot to remind you the
suggestions are a 1980s wood carver
convention
midsummer maypole getting mcdonald's at
3am after the club
uh big mac and loads of nuggets the
magic of the rice cooker and an nft
version of a van gogh painting
and as always do not worry it's not
anywhere near as atrociously
embarrassingly toe-curlingly bad
as you're expecting a privately educated
middle-class white boy to be
let's uh let's get this beat i'm excited
this is a
a pretty banging beat ah
yeah mike can't wait
kicking up a fuss you can call it palava
take that lathe cause i'm a wood carver
everybody standing to attention
displaying my skills at the
convention wait [ __ ] [ __ ] i didn't come
in at the start of the beat
wind it back wind it back dj wind it
back now i've got to come up with a
different rhyme for wood carver
oh i hate myself okay
four beats let's all count to get five
six it's like primary school rhymes
seven
smile on the face roll in with glee when
i stand right there and i carve that
tree chop it down
oh lug it on my back i walk into the
hall like a lumberjack but this guy
oh all of my mateys gather around here
in the 1980s
just guys no ladies when it comes wood
carving we're crazy
oh take that bandsaw never seen
something this smooth before i gotta get
that sandpaper
it's a hit use 50 120 180 grit
gotta graduate up the levels oh see a
little tree and a level
out with a bandsaw out with a foam mid
summer maple got one in my home cause
i'm in stockholm like the guys call ben
and rebecca oh yes that's the king among
men
run around there yeah you know i heard
or go anti-clockwise inside that circle
hello it's me a man from the land of
sweet
done walk round with a little white
dress and the long blonde hair you can
measure these tresses oh
ethnic purity that's what the swedes all
want to see
whoa chris why'd you go over there when
it's at 3am in the club losing my hair
gel all of my hair spray call him right
out i'll be going oh i need some food in
my mouth
tommy rumbly when i'm out of the club
and i stand in line at my dolls and i
rub like oh
i just can't wait getting that big mac
while salivate
his master's voice that pavlovian
reaction and you know i'm going in even
though the nuggets are frozen in the
fryer i take them i put them in my bag
and aspire to eat them they're on the
bus when going home
maybe an uber pool not the one on my own
oh have a look there when i'm in china
get the rice cooker people pick it out
from the paddy fields
you can get a little bit it's a mad
yield never steal one of those buy it
from qvc
rice cooker makes it so easy doesn't
even matter if you measure it enough you
can match that liquid and the rice in
the cup like
one each or one and a half you can make
it more moist like a bubbly bath
rice cookers that's all magic anybody
with a one pop tragic
i prefer to have that like slow get
released when the steam coming through
when i'm eating the beef
that's when you cook it kind of slow
it's a thing put the chili in like it's
coming from jim jinping
that's the leader of the communist
country last one don't hunt me down if i
say that
nfts are all a whack why cause they're
burning the carbon the sky turning black
ethereum mining very bad yeah put the
time
in you can study the carbon emission is
putting the country in lower positions
but still
cutting off fear cause i'm so so low
feeling depressed like vincent van gogh
had that sex with a prostitute but she
was like no vincent i'm cross with you
he said oh
i got a lot to do but still don't need
to hear through
one he's a sad little dutch fellow we
can't ever hear no more stereo because
there's no lobe so he chops it off he's
like
oh i've got a chesty cough i'm gonna die
quite soon suicide gun shot but don't
worry nft gonna drop that
coming there online in an hour you can
bid on ebay for the sunflowers nft so
your own it
there but non-fungible token that's the
little acronym uh
and that was almost broken by the fact
the beat faded but there you go that is
the wrapper all that
ah the universe will not end with a bang
but with a whimper
as all my raps do just fading out gently
that's what we like